the Prime Minister and her Chancellor
longtime political soulmate Neighbors in
Downing Street but today thousands of
miles apart as pressure to U-turn mounts
further quasiquarting in Washington now
says let's see if his mini budget still
stands but insists he's going nowhere
our position hasn't changed I will come
up with the medium-term fiscal plan on
the 31st of October as I said earlier in
the week and there'll be more detail
there and you'll be Chancellor and Liz
truss will be prime minister this time
next month absolutely 100 I'm not going
anywhere in here skynees understands
conversations are underway on whether to
scrap some of this government's first
major decisions which have destabilized
the Market's upset voters LED MPS to
question the PM's future cabinet
ministers asked where the u-turns are
coming open that they aren't sure what's
happening next I think you know that I'm
not in a position to answer your
question this afternoon I'm going to
have to say that quite straightforwardly
to you and any one else who would like
to ask the same question as you know
that will be a matter for the chancellor
to announce some due course there are
still some loyalists to the PM's cause
[Music]
yes she does
in number 10 looking at the numbers in
Parliament worry there's no way through
Tory big beasts also see a U-turn as
inevitable there's an irony to this
birth which is Market forces will
probably dictate some of these changes
now so you think they'll be bounced I
think I think some of this you know the
market is going to dictate this
primarily because you know we want to
see stability stability is absolute
crucial all eyes on the chancellor
scheduled to head back to the UK
tomorrow
quasi-quarting flying back here to
Downing Street to thrash out what
happens next he's barely being
Chancellor for six weeks alongside Liz
truss as prime minister yet already the
strains are showing whether it's on the
top rate of tax or the bank of England
or which civil servant should run the
treasury now it looks very much like Liz
truss wants to take back control of
decisions from that mini budget will he
go along with her where does that leave
him
this former chancellor has weathered
multiple crises in his time he says he's
not seen anything like this before it's
in a really disastrous hole yes I've
never known a government made such a
catastrophic start uh to his period of
office say quasi goes that actually
won't do her much good I don't think it
will just be an obvious case of Escape
goating her partner her closest
political Ally for the mistakes had been
made she should just take it on the chin
behind closed doors treasury
photographer in tow the chancellor eager
to show himself performing on the world
stage mending fences soothing nerves but
even here he knows Trouble Is Coming Sam
coats Sky News Westminster